un peu plus d'une semaine après le drame
à frontenaud les circonstances de la
mort de guy matte et inquiète les chiens
n'ont pas été retrouvés impossible de
savoir s'ils sont toujours dans le
secteur
ça fait pas louis et puis je te pour les
enfants quoi et puis les personnes qui
se promènent à pied s'ils sont un ou
deux puis que ils ont repris un état pas
pour dire sauvage mais de faire des
bêtises et ben voilà on peut se faire
attaquer c'est ici à deux kilomètres du
village que l'éleveur de labrador a été
retrouvé mort selon l'autopsié il a
succombé à une crise cardiaque et non
pas aux morsures qu'il a subi mais pour
éviter un nouvel accident
la préfecture de saône et loire a pris
un arrêté autorisant l'abattage des
animaux errants dans un communiqué il
demande aux habitants de procéder à des
signalements auprès de la gendarmerie et
de ne rien faire eux mêmes mais le ou
les chiens responsables sont ils
toujours credo fonteneau pour les
chasseurs de la commune
impossible de le savoir si on fait une
battue sur frontenaud c'est pas obligés
qu'ils soient là quoi je veux dire on
peut ratisser tous fonteneau et puis pas
trouvé de chiens errants à mon avis un
chien il fait beaucoup de chemin
si c'est un chien qui n'appartient à
personne vit peut être deux trois
communes d'ici ou où elle pèse sur la
commune ça on n'en sait rien du côté de
la mairie de ce village de 700 habitants
on tient à rappeler des consignes
simples de sécurité il faut savoir
raison garder bien sûr mais en même
temps être très vigilants par rapport à
chiens dont on peut être propriétaire
les encadrer correctement éviter au
maximum qu'il soit en divagation et puis
être vigilant par rapport à
l'observation de ce qui se passe autour
de nous pour rappel la loi prévoit qu'en
cas d' attaque d'un animal domestique
c'est son propriétaire qui sera tenue
responsable des dommages causés